it is dope that the court ruled against
uh newsome
to be like dude [ __ ] off yeah like him
like trying to
like dictate people's thanksgivings and
holidays and [ __ ] and
you can only do this and what he's doing
to businesses like disney and stuff he
lost that
in court oh that's basically like dude
chill the [ __ ] out get a boy he's just a
bad
so disney can open back up they're going
to open up sooner now yeah just trying
to can't control
disneyland disneyland who the [ __ ]
trying to go to disneyland
what wow unbelievable all right thank
you girl man
you went to i have you went to skate
park yesterday
[Laughter]
bro that is not like you're gonna judge
people at disneyland
here's but here's it [ __ ] disneyland
let's say you guys don't like disney
fine cool
okay the problem is the economy how many
jobs thousands of jobs
those people can't work and they're
laying those people off come on like did
you get a job at a skate park
there drops to skateboarding he was
making a point yeah continue
um you [ __ ] it up
disneyland is the biggest employer of
everybody in orange county in california
in all of california the biggest
employer sorry kennedy
yeah it's a big deal yeah so it [ __ ]
those families over man
i know i love magic kingdom yeah what is
that it's [ __ ] great
is that six flags no it's this this
isn't it
that's the one it is magic you can
google that no there's magic kingdom
is like the main i almost got into a
fight with goofy yeah that's like the
castle although i will tell you i did
like the ride uh so i got my girlfriend
she wanted to go to disneyland for
she wanted those so you have one for
christmas yeah okay and
uh we went on my birthday but um i did
like the um
wait did you go on your birthday or
christmas well we went on my birthday
but it was her christmas present
okay but i did like that one ride that's
at california adventure
it's the family of superheroes it's the
roller coaster
has the loop what's that family of
superheroes oh the incredibles one
incredibles one yeah that roller coaster
was pretty cool we talked about
classic [ __ ] disneyland dude haunted
house come on man
splash mountain treasure island the cars
the cars dog
cars is in california yeah it is it's
great yeah
i haven't been to the one in orlando big
thunder mountain railroad
that's cars now i've been on indiana
jones oh they still got the matterhorn
uh-huh i've been on that they got the
weight limit on india john cruz
you're fine no i've been yeah i've been
to disneyland like the past like
two years doug when it was like popping
we have a season pass
my son and my girl would go twice a week
i [ __ ] with the food do you do the fast
pass
yeah of course come on you gotta have to
do that it's different now where uh you
have to buy
like a fast pass and it's fast-paced for
all the rides yeah
so before what you would do is your
ticket every ticket you could get as
many fast passes
as you want but it's within a time frame
so if you got one for magic kingdom
that's from 2 30 to 3 30
you couldn't get any that would
interfere with that time so you have to
wait until you use that up
and then get another one wait your ass
ain't too big for a roller coaster
no not at disneyland did you know did
you know the uh
ohio they have the best uh america's
number one theme park the uh
they're um kings island kings island
kings island yes when i lived in
louisville uh
all a lot of people from my team would
always go to kings island king island
number one that's the
that's their damn eighteen thousand bro
dog me stevie and jay went to
six flags and we're
we're in texas somewhere we went to six
flags out there sounds about right
dude i went on one roller coaster and i
was
done for the day oh bro i can't i can't
last that long it's
such a bummer him as a kid you ain't
before do you know
like all of us got sick we went on one
roller coaster everyone was like it must
have been a batman ride
yeah yeah i was batman we went on batman
i guess what's that one
you're like hanging like yeah hanging
horizontal like
a video of it batman yeah batman you fly
like batman yeah although batman doesn't
fly
he does yeah that makes sense yeah he
doesn't no he doesn't you don't like it
he's super big he glides batman one and
then they have the joker one too what
about oh dude that was
that would [ __ ] me up what about the
handle what about the
what about the fun what about the x-man
one did you have you been on that it's
like
it goes you backwards so it starts off
oh yeah yeah that
reversed the whole we went on two of
them and then i gave some family our
passes well how much when they're
walking in okay because we one on two
rides is like hey these are good for all
[ __ ] day
yeah okay no i'm not talking about that
chance god damn no
no people don't
i know right have you guys you guys been
to the six flags and uh was it santa
vince yeah santa clarita i've been to
that one i've also been to the one
in the bay area in vallejo both are
great yeah six flags i love theme parks
i love theme parks but i'm afraid i'm
gonna get to that point where i get
older and i just can't ride rides
anymore
i know it's a bummer i think i need
dramamine or something something
you've been in knott's very farm yes you
talking about the spare errors of
amusing parts
not not when it's not scary for him is
nice
dude knott's berry farm first of all
past that yeah we can't roll you need
they need to
upgrade they need a spirit airline
they need to upgrade their [ __ ] first of
all
i was there with my uh family like two
years ago
i was so disappointed first of all you
know what their main characters are
you know you know how when you go to
disneyland it's mickey
it's [ __ ] the cars it's shrek it's
dope [ __ ]
you go to the other one it's batman
you got [ __ ] the spiderman you know
what it is at
knott's berry farm what is it it's
charlie brown
[Applause]
my son was like who the [ __ ] is that and
i was like
so you know when i was a kid even for me
i'm like yeah that's what i'm like
i don't think the young people's movie
so great
did it just kind of yeah for adults no
it came out probably like four or five
years ago
it was great but no think about it like
charlie brown's got it
like compared to mickey and [ __ ]
shrek and cars
i'm not gonna argue that you're right
but let's just go back to you dude they
had the most
busted rides they still had a wooden
ride yeah
dude i do got that little you don't know
if it's broke ours oh
god i'm [ __ ] with that one they have
the one they have the the
seats that are on chains chain links and
then it spins around oh yeah
this [ __ ] is not safe bruh it was a
couple of rides
so ratchet they still got like funnel
cakes everywhere they haven't upgraded
their menu still that [ __ ] is so
old-school you ever hear that story i
think daniel tosh tells it on a special
where there was a kid whose hat fell off
on a roller coaster
i think i told you that no daniel tosh
doesn't know oh he does a bit
what happened in my hometown
you know what i'm going to say yeah you
didn't even know what i was going to say
you cut me off before hold on
i know i know what you're saying what is
going on is it where the kid he's
mentally handicapped his hat flies off
he goes down to get it and then
someone's going on the road coach goes
cool face
kaku she kills the kid yeah yep that
happened
i know i got it i called him out
i think the worker tried to get the hat
because i don't think the kid was
allowed to go into that area you know
the kid that danced
he was a kid really the kid the kid had
some sort of
issue mm-hmm
yes wait so his also happened on the
rainbow at ilitch's too
well how long was the ride for him to go
down there it's a roller coaster though
you know how there's like that pit where
like the pictures are taken georgia
yeah oh it's georgia yeah this is what
we're talking about colorado
something happened colorado though take
your dab back right
well there's a different story though
yeah so it says hat yep
yeah jump the fence to retrieve the hat
yep
oh god do me a favor type in uh teen
dies
in uh six flags denver
also known as elitch gardens over the
same thing over the same pretty sure but
as a kid with uh i think in a down
syndrome
now i might be making this up okay oh
there you go
nope that's not it that's not it nope
because it didn't happen no i'm telling
you one kid got [ __ ] up
over a hat would you type in denver
let's try colorado are depths common and
theme parks
i don't want to see no caught on tape
[ __ ] well i want to see what they have
28 year old killing denver six flat east
gardens girl who's oh there you go click
on that dog oh
he's in arizona he ate
no denver told ya oh okay he's different
[ __ ]
i wouldn't yep but still i knew still
yeah he was right there but daniel
tasha's right
we got one amusement park a man fell to
his death might have to stand up
damn it fell to his death uh
attracted six flags and me apart uh
struck in the head one day after the
georgia one that's why
um struck hitting the head by a
passenger staying late 20 year old uh
killed in denver six flag elich garden
shout out to old school elite gardens
whose name was not released the deaths
we investigate okay he was killed on
right called the rainbow
called it let me tell what the rainbow
does shaped like big gay rainbow
and then there's an arm on it it goes
i don't think you're doing it like yeah
i'm pretty sure he's like wait doesn't
he
do it better i'm pretty sure he took his
seat belt off uh
what all no accessories are clear hope
scrub chin
um i'm sure we're talking about the
georgia ones like the straps
oh there he goes mentally challenged
individuals dude
i knew it i said the wrong ride wrong
state yeah
all right you good we have one there he
goes the witness report that the man
unlatched his seat belt and worked his
way out of the lap bar restraining that
[ __ ] is tough you know how tough those
lap bars are yeah
he he pulled it up beast
huh how strong was he official
he always said i was like i'm not gonna
jump in that world
don't you are you curious no no don't be
any more curious
six flags over uh george by the 58 year
old man walked in lock no access batman
all right
yeah it's tough damn y'all got a lot of
music parts back home
uh as a kid my favorite was water world
shout out to water world
and then there's uh south shores which
is great shut down
yeah then there were i think everybody
had a water world yeah i didn't have one
we had
some version we had raging waters in san
jose oh
that's basically out there you ever
heard of that do you guys have the lazy
river
yup the lazy river that everyone went in
impeding i was just gonna say i used to
piss
everybody out did y'all have like a wave
pool at you
yeah yeah standard yeah yeah yeah yeah
did you
allow you to have like uh the floaties
oh yeah you ever seen the asians get
[ __ ] up yeah
oh my god there's one guy like riding it
you know i've seen it something goes
wrong there's like a malfunction it puts
a
tsunami on there yeah no and it's like
it's like somewhere in china or japan
so it's real floaties and then the
thing malfunctions yeah look at these
get the [ __ ] out of here why is there so
many of them look like a joke
you guys are trying to get me in trouble
today you guys are dangling
why is there so many of them brendan
look at this
everyone's like what the [ __ ]
malfunction son
oh stop oh it supposed to stop it ain't
supposed to go that far
yeah [ __ ] people up oh
damn wait that look like a normal way
that looks not too bad
it does this is six minutes long doug
okay let's see let's watch it let's look
at another one
there's no actual wave trying to always
trying to do it bigger
ooh look at that that ain't normal
that's it yeah yeah that's kind of
what's gonna happen
everyone's terrified that's what the
phone is running yeah we get about it
oh good luck getting out of there
everyone's like uh i guess i'll just
hang on
you know some [ __ ] put pushed a
different button dog is there
anything more exhausting than going to a
water park
and you're in the sun all day you got
aqua socks on
you probably ate some funnel cakes
you're full of sugar you're obsessed
with this food
you're exhausted by the day by the end
of the day at a water bottle yeah you're
done
you know what exactly for your life
after that i fell asleep driving home
bro yeah i was driving i fell asleep oh
did you yep
you know what's so ironic about water
parks they ate the waters
uh they sell there ten dollars oh yeah
bro
this stuff is expensive at a water park
that's what's weird like at the airport
starbucks is more expensive at the
airport
why the [ __ ] you charge more yeah
because you're in the airport well they
know you can't go anywhere yeah man you
want coffee
there you go yeah that's true how about
that when i get off stage at the lab
factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son